let's shift gears here a little bit
after the horrible tragedy the act of
terror that took place in New York City
last week where a Muslim man from
Uzbekistan ran over multiple people in
New York City with a truck that he
rented from Home Depot killing some
injuring others the president Donald
Trump said that they have decided to
start hitting Isis ten times harder
since and in response to that incident
here's video of Donald Trump talking
about this renewed Isis strategy as a
result of the New York City attack what
we're doing is every time we're attacked
from this point forward and it took
place yesterday we are hitting them ten
times harder so when we have an animal
to an attack like he did the other day
on the west side of Manhattan we are
hitting them ten times harder
they claimed him as a soldier good luck
it wasn't just before leaving to Asia
that Donald Trump did this he also took
to Twitter and made similar comments
where he said Isis just claimed the
degenerate animal who killed and so
badly wounded the wonderful people on
the west side was their soldier based on
that the military has hit Isis much
harder over the last two days they will
pay a big price for every attack on us
pretty clear right we had the attack in
New York and now we're hitting Isis
harder unfortunately there's no evidence
whatsoever that that's true in terms of
airstrikes the u.s. coalition did 24
airstrikes against Isis in Iraq and
Syria
that's down significantly from the same
amount of time in October the Defense
Department reported that the u.s. did
carry out two airstrikes against Isis
targets in northeastern Somalia early on
Friday that's the first time that Isis
has been targeted by American aircraft
in Somalia it's unclear whether Trump
was referring to that probably not
because he doesn't really know anything
but more importantly the Pentagon was
asked about this and they said
effectively they're not doing anything
differently since the New York terror
incident Trump just made it up out of
thin air asked to explain the Pentagon
said to Newsweek quote while we
cannot speak to the global fight against
- we can tell you that the coalition and
its partners have continued to
consistently unrelentingly take the
fight to - terrorists in Iraq and Syria
over the past three years Trump says
since last week's attack we're hitting
Isis ten times harder the Pentagon is
asked to comment and they say it's been
three years of going after Isis we've
been going hard and we continue to go
hard so very often it's not that Trump
is slightly wrong right it's that he's
completely wrong Trump says we're
hitting them ten times harder in
response to the attack the data says
nothing has changed and in fact over the
last few weeks we've been hitting Isis
less hard and the Pentagon says we
effectively don't know what it is that
Donald Trump is talking about but if his
supporters feel that it's true in their
heart of hearts maybe it is true on some
level maybe or maybe not I don't know